hello everyone and welcome to the pen
ultimate round of this year's Tata steel
Chess Masters uh with an incredible
moment in chess history if you guys uh
know what I'm talking about you're
welcome to just skip to the moment uh in
the time section below the video but if
you don't know what's what happened do
watch the entire video so it's round 12
GES versus Pagan going into round 12 not
ABD satov is leading the tournament but
of course with a victory PR could get
close to him and gu could get even
closer to him so uh let's check out what
happened here as it's uh really really
incredible and also it's even more
incredible that it happened specifically
on move 40 uh just on the move that you
have to reach in order to reach time
control so here uh GES with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to D4 at Knight
to F6 by Prague we have Pawn to C4 and
now Pawn to E6 going for some sort of an
Indian defense we have Knight to C3 and
Bishop to B4 Theo Indian defense is is
on the board we have Knight to F3
castles and now uh Bishop to G5 so a
fairly standard idea and now Pawn to C5
but uh not going for something like E3
or Rook to C1 here we have Pawn to D5 so
going uh into sort of a benoni nimzo
structure we have e captures and D5 C
captures Pawn to D6 so basically a Boni
with with a bishop on B4 uh we have Pawn
to E3 and now Pawn to H6 chasing away
guish is Bishop on G5 Bishop to H4 and
now Bishop to F5 there is a game that
reached this position Knight B to D7 was
played it was played in 2021 Leon
babujan versus bdan Daniel deak and deak
lost that game but here we have Bishop
to F5 by Prague and it is now as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
so okay gukesh continues developing
Bishop to D3 Pro tray of the light
Square Bishops and now Knight B to D7 we
have castles uh and Rook to E8 uh so you
know fighting for that E4 Square we have
Knight to E2 uh and now Pawn to A6 it's
interesting that um Knight the E5
although it looks very nice doesn't
really do all that much for example you
can just trade and then play Pawn uh or
even capture on F6 Bishop captures Queen
captures and queen to B5 uh is very
annoying goes after the B7 pawn and if
B6 um even A3 just traps the bishop so
there are problems like that you could
go Bishop D2 then Rook Rook to D1 then
the Bishop has to go to A5 and then of
course B4 traps the bishop so instead uh
after Knight E2 we have Pawn to A6 and
now Queen to F5 okay just putting more
pressure on prague's King Side Pawn to
C4 a very standard idea in the Bon Rook
to C1 going after the pawn and Rook 8 to
C8 defending the pawn we have A3 chasing
away the bishop Bishop to A5 and now
Knight to G3 we have Queen to E7 uh and
now Queen back to H3 freeing up the F5
Square for the Knight to put pressure on
the queen and on the D6 pawn and in all
sorts of Boni structures the D6 Pawn
usually is a weakness we have Rook to C5
now putting pressure on the D5 pawn and
first Knight to F5 chasing away the
queen we have Queen f8 you have to keep
an eye on that D6 pawn and now Rook F to
D1 guarding the D5 Pawn we have Bishop
to d8 and now Rook to D4 just putting
pressure on the C for Pawn but also with
some ideas of later on transferring the
bishop uh The Rook over to the king side
to help out with the attack and now Pawn
to B5 of course just defending the C4
Pawn with Bishop to
G3 now with the threat of just Bishop
captures and D6 this would win the game
for GES and Prague defends with Knight
to E5 so uh putting a knight in between
the bishop and the D6 Pawn we have Rook
C to D D1 doubling up on the dile and
now Knight to H7 preparing Knight to G5
to put pressure on the queen and maybe
even trade off some pieces so Bishop to
F4 but still Knight Knight to G5 we have
Queen to G3 by gkes and now prog trades
with Knight G captures on F3 with check
uh G captures on F3 now guash says I
might even move my king and bring the
Rooks over to the G file to help out
with the attack against the black king
king to H7 and now Queen to H3 we have
Bishop to E7 adding another Defender
here uh and now uh Rook to E4 just
piling up on that Knight on E5 and here
uh Prague well there are a couple of
moves he could play he goes for Rook to
d8 an interesting way to counter this is
Knight to D3 I will show it because it's
fairly brief and after Knight captures
on E7 you go Knight captures on F4
that's the idea and now okay if Queen F5
check you will play Knight to G6 block
check and after everything gets traded
off here you have this um rook and pawn
end game okay D F3 is hanging you will
defend it with F4 but all in all it's a
it's a it's a drawish end game uh but
Prague wanted more he played Rook to d8
and now King to G2 but both of them are
burning aot a lot of time in this game
and both of them are already reaching
below the 5 minute Mark we have Pon A5
by prag trying to push on the queen side
to create a pass pawn and now Rook D to
D4 now interestingly uh if gkes had more
time he was already down to two minutes
on the clock uh he could he would find
Bishop captures uh Pawn captures and now
Pawn to D6 just
um almost trapping that Bishop on E7 and
after Bishop to G5 Pawn to F4 and after
captures captures the bishop to F6 and
now Pawn to D7 and you know with two
minutes on the clock it's hard to uh
hard to decide whether this Pawn will be
safe or not but um objectively it is
best for white however here we have Rook
D to D4 and now proc plays Pawn to C3
it's not a good move because the pawn
cannot be captured back which gash
calculates properly he plays B captures
on C3 and Prague captures back and now
there's a problem the game is now
completely winning for gash so feel free
to pause the video uh and win the game
for gash while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
This brilliant resource and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is a rook captures on E5 that's the move
that Prague missed and the thing he
missed is that after the captures on E5
and Bishop captures on E5 uh well
whatever he plays he's just lost now uh
G7 is hanging so the move you really
want to play is Bishop to F6 but you
cannot play that if you play Bishop to
F6 then look at this bishop captures G
captures now Rook to H4 and that's it
how are you defending the the H6 Pawn if
you go Queen to G8 with check uh you can
even play Rook to G4 not even you have
to play it otherwise you know you're
going to be in trouble if you go to the
back rank so you have to play Rook G4
attack the queen and after Queen to f8
something like Queen H4 and this will be
enough for white to win let's say you
will have to give a little bit of
material back to guard the pawn here uh
Rook to D6 white will happily take it
and now you're going to play Queen to H5
go after the F7 Pawn uh black will
defend it and now Rook to H4 attack this
Pawn the only way to defend it is to
give up the F5 pawn queen captures an F5
with check and after let's say queen G6
you will even capture play Rook to D4
start advancing the pawns here and
you're up two Pawns of course completely
winning um end game
so uh Bishop to F6 does not work for
Prague but you know even bigger problem
for Prague is that he is down to 3
minutes in the clock but gukesh is even
lower he's down to two minutes on the
clock so prog played Pawn to F6 to mdy
the waters Here and Now Pawn to D6 by
guesh trapping the bishop on E7 and okay
there's nothing for prog to do here he
has to take it Bishop captures on D6
Bishop Capt attacking the queen and
queen to F7 now we have Rook to G4
gukesh is now of course completely
winning he has um two pieces for the
rook and Rook to G8 you have to guard um
the the the G7 and the H6 pawns here uh
Bishop to F4 piling up on the H6 pawn
and now Queen to f8 prag barely holding
on here and here GES played Bishop to D6
and now look at this uh Bishop to D6
Queen to F7 Bishop back to F4 and now
Queen to f8 and here believe it or not
guesh played Bishop to D6 this is move
39 he needed to make one more move to
reach time control uh but he played
Bishop to D6 and he could play pretty
much any other move in his position
would still be winning he could just
move the Rook Rook H4 Rook to G3 uh put
the bishop on G3 it doesn't really
matter play Pawn to E4 any move you make
here pretty much any move and he will
continue having a winning position
reaching move 40 he will be granted
additional time and he will have enough
time to figure out how he wants to win
this game but he played Bishop to D6 and
here Prague pressed the clock called The
Arbiter and he uh you know said that it
was a threefold repetition or rather he
just you know showed showed the score
sheet to the to the Arbiter and the
Arbiter confirmed that it is a
three-fold repetition once black plays
Pawn to F7 Queen to F7 so uh in order
for you to uh see the repetition and to
realize what a repetition is because
some of you uh I've realized also think
that it's a repetition of moves like um
I move the king you move the Rook that's
not a repetition of moves it is a
repetition of moves but it's completely
relevant to what happened here here a
position repeated itself not the not not
that moves were repeated of course you
had to repeat repeat moves for the
position to repeat itself but sometimes
you can also repeat moves without the
the position repeating itself so this is
the uh position so first after Rook to
G4 uh now Rook to G8 was played so this
is the first position that we are taking
into consideration uh then Bishop back
to F4 was played Queen to f8 Bishop to
D6 and queen to F7 the position repeated
itself twice and now after Bishop to F4
PR played Queen to F7 and Bishop to D6
here with Queen to F7 uh the position
repeated itself three times uh Prague
you know advertised it correctly and he
saved this game and he saved his winning
streak everyone thought okay prague's
winning streak is now gone gues played
the brilliant game uh you know he slowly
squeezed prag prag didn't have enough
time to calculate he blundered with that
pawn to C3 move Rook captures on C3 and
GES just played a brilliant game but no
uh prag fights until the absolute very
end and he was able to save this game I
don't I don't think uh well I probably
seen it but I don't remember seeing it
in a very very long time on move 40 you
know with uh and uh gkes was down to I
don't know maybe a few seconds on the
clock so he played Bishop to D6 thinking
that uh he was the one that is creating
the position that repeats itself not
prag with Queen to F7 he thought that
prag has to play Queen to F7 and then he
will play something else and then the
position will not repeat itself but yeah
he Mis miscounted the the positions uh
you know in hand uh so yeah a tough
break for gues he was on his weight um
maybe even taking the lead in the
tournament we still don't know what
happened in the abdulov game as he's
still fighting with it even as I'm
recording this video maybe he's not let
me just check no he's they're still
fighting uh wait let me just
see yeah it's a very very slow end game
so they're still playing it um I I could
give you an update on what I think will
happen but no let's not spoil it I will
make another video regarding that
situation but now let's turn to the one
of the other games that also finished uh
maybe tomorrow I'm also going to show
what happened in the game yordan f
Forest versus Anish giri because that
was a terrible terrible blunder
basically you know the game just started
and you know piece was blundered uh but
the game I wanted to show you is um ala
versus Yan pishi also a really big
matchup both of them candidates of the
of the candidates tournament that will
be played in three months so uh let's
check out this one really a masterful
display so here alza opened with Knight
to C3 it's the vanit opening uh and uh
okay Yan really had no idea what to play
here but uh you know you can pretty much
play anything as it's not a serious
opening on the other hand it can
transpose into pretty much any other
opening so he has to be careful in what
what he plays D4 we have Pawn to D5 and
now Bishop to F4 ala goes for sort of a
an accelerated London system we have
Pawn to C5 and now E3 C captures and D4
e captures Pawn to A6 and now Knight to
F3 okay so it uh has been played before
nothing new here Bishop to G4 H3 Bishop
captures Queen captures and Knight to C6
so nicely developing pieces both of them
Queen side Castles by alza and now Pawn
to E6 we have Pawn to G4 maybe with
ideas of advancing the pawn to G5
kicking away the knight uh but just a
nice calm Bishop to D6 by Yan uh Bishop
back to E three and here there is a game
where Rook to C8 was played but here we
have Queen to A5 and it is now as of
move 11 that we have a completely new
game so okay King to B1 now the Knight
can move you don't have to worry about
the A2 pawn and now Knight to B4 now the
Knight can't move you have to worry
about the A2 Pawn so Bishop back to C1
we have Rook to C8 and now Pawn to A3
kicking away Yan's Knight Knight to C6
and now ala presses forward on the king
Side Pawn to G5 we have kn D7 and pawn
to H4 uh okay Queen to B6 putting
pressure on the on the king Bishop
captures on A3 is the threat so uh
Bishop to H3 a very very tricky move
objectively Rook to H3 was best but
Bishop to H3 keeps Yan King in the
center of the board now the problem is
if you Castle then there's this Knight
captures on D5 trick and if Pawn
captures then the bishop captures the
Knight on D7 that's the idea behind
Bishop to H3 but uh also uh Kent Yan
just play Bishop captures on A3 here
well if you play Bishop captures on A3
again you run into this Knight captures
on D5 line and the bishop here protects
against Checkmate uh if you capture also
the Knight will uh be captured with
check and also the queen now attacks the
bishop on A3 so ala did think of
everything so after Bishop to H3 Yan
played Knight captures and D4 as ala did
give up a pawn Here and Now Queen to E3
putting pressure on Yan's Knight Bishop
to E5 and now Pawn to F4 so why did Yan
allow this why did Yan grab a pawn for
for for this Knight if he moves the
bishop back ala just wins a piece here
well uh Yan's idea was uh go for the
attack Rook captures and C3 Queen
captures and C3 and now just Knight to
B5 with the idea of Knight to C5 and
then he has everything in the attack
here uh so okay Queen to F3 only only
good move for alza but also the one that
wins the game for him uh the bishop
still hanging here and now Bishop to D4
uh we have King A2 getting the King off
of the off of the B file and now uh Pawn
to G6 stopping the advancement of the F
and the H pawns but Pawn to H5 it
doesn't stop it but it you know
minimizes the damage uh Knight to C5 by
on and now Bishop to F1 masterfully
delivered by Ala just opens up the H
file for The Rook preparing H captures
on G5 so this is impossible you'll have
to capture with the F Pawn this will
weaken the E6 pawn and then I'll is
hoping to press forward we have Knight
to E4 uh getting the Knight closer to
the to the white king but also closing
off the E file and now Bishop captures
on B5 with check doesn't matter what you
capture with uh I mean it does as if you
capture with the queen then Queen is no
longer guarding the D4 Bishop so a
captures on B5 and now H captures on G6
we have F captures on G6 and now just
Rook H to A1 Rook H to E1 and um very
difficult position for Yan uh also you
could play Pawn to F5 here but it's
unnecessary to go for such uh uh you
know engine trickery Rook H to E1 is
also incredibly strong so here Yan
played Rook to f8 and the position is
now completely winning for ala but you
have to you have to find the move that
he played and also what what is so
terrible that Yan missed here uh while I
give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding that
the bishop on D4 is the problem and also
that the king is getting checkmated uh
how is the king getting checkmated with
so much stuff in front of the black king
well that's the beauty of Chess here
alza just played Queen to D3 and he was
in this position un move 28 that Yan
pishi resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here problem is
next move alza just wins a piece and if
Yan moves it doesn't really matter where
let's say Bishop to C5 then Rook
captures on e4 and Yan is unable to
capture back and then ala is just up
material with you know a very strong
attack against the black king of course
if Pawn captures then Queen D7 is
Checkmate so uh very very tough loss for
Yan he didn't really figure out how to
go about this whole Knight to C3
business but yeah ala takes down a
candidate with the vanit opening Knight
to C3 so yeah even that has happened but
yeah crazy I mean this is this is such a
crazy round ala defeating Yan pish with
Knight C3 guesh forcing a threefold
repetition in a winning position against
Prague and move 40 uh Jordan uh
completely blundering you know pretty
much in in the opening a full piece
against Anish giri and you know other
stuff is happening also but I'm going to
make make another video on this round uh
probably after all of the games have
finished and then we're going to discuss
uh what what is up uh before the final
round of the Tata steel 20 24 uh so
that's the game or rather those were the
games hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Lana is the best wife in
the world Samuel Kane ghard hlan Hans
Anderson and David gasparian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day